hi everyone I'm idil and I'm gonna tell
you ten things you didn't know about me
[Applause]
when I'm in a bad mood I listen to fish
go deep during the course because it is
a great feel good song didn't do them
you will never find me in my life that's
the first thing that comes to my head
but I just do not like my life so
definitely that was near me in there in
bed I am a still sleeper I stay in the
same spot when I go to sleep so when I
wake up in the morning like I do not
move an inch
my mother is I hope that she is lovely
what I wear what I want to be a badass
it's probably some heels shorts and a
crop top like as much skin as possible
then I feel like I shut down a is by
laughing at them in my most private
moment you'll find me having a bath with
candles everywhere
into oceans I was try to relax before
bed my guilty pleasure is burnt
chocolates like when you put a bar of
plain chocolate into the microwave
burning so it's crumbly
the rules I live by is sleep is your
best friend doesn't matter how much
makeup you've got if you're naked you
will be able to tell us which I asleep
as much as possible so note to myself as
well and yeah cold spoon so a spoon in
the fridge in the morning when you've
got puffy eyes put spoons on your eyes
for about two minutes my perfect date
night is he hasn't actually happened but
like driving up to a hill somewhere
where you can see a mess of you having a
bottle of wines and Cray's snaps and
just like watching the stars and listen
to music that be I do now it for me but
make sure you comment like and share and
don't forget okay
you